your skin is so nice is it impeccable
really dude it's like it's improved
actually improved it's perfect you do
any like treatments and stuff like
facial I have but I haven't done
recently wait till you see this guy's
skin when he gets in you know I can't
even I want to know what he gets done
you think he'll say it's crazy one day
like a couple years ago when I went to
Korea he let me crash at his place and I
remember like taking a shower at his
place and I was taking pictures of all
his product so I can see like what he
uses and stuff cuz this skin is like
crazy I don't I mean but Korea also has
so many places you can go to I know and
they do it so well like Bobby we should
go there just as for like on a beauty
trip I need Beauty we need to get the
the liver spots out we need to um I want
the baby dick cream that Sandra Bullock
uses you can get that here though I want
the no I want from Korean put the baby
the CR would you do some stuff on your
face like botox injections and stuff no
never no no would you no I said never oh
you would never do it okay didn't I just
say that yeah I I'm sorry you're right
my tone but we were supposed to do the
micro needling and the laser together I
want to do it I did a vampire facial was
did it did you feel like it helped I did
I think it did I did it like three times
couple months you you you're a Korean
vampire if they had a movie I'm not
doesn't he look like he's been around
for thousands of years I look like a
vampire yeah you know who we need to get
this skin um regimen of Daniel
deim yeah but he's got great skin too he
could play a good vampire too I think he
would be a good vampire yeah for sure
yeah um I have to admit when Jay yuck
that's the vampire facial it okay where
they poke holes in your face when Jay
and when we went to the club for the
first time I've gone out with him a
couple times dinner and stuff but the
first time he looked at me at the club
we were sitting at that thing yeah and I
was like I think I'm about to suck this
guy's dick I mean I it was I mean he
looked at me he's so cute there was a
look that he gave me that I
blushed I was just like what's the look
I I can't do his look you when you meet
him you'll see you'll blush it is
interesting when I see dudes that kind
of look like that like they were born to
be like a K-pop Star yeah dude you're
like damn you can't really work any
other job really like how could you just
pretty imagine J Park working at Pet
Boys that would be insane that would be
insane that would be insane like am I in
a movie right now I mean it would be
crazy that would be crazy yeah yeah yeah
uh or like you know Henry Lao was like
that too right right right they I did I
did a movie with Henry yeah and every
time I would look at him there's look at
him oh that's right there's look at his
face look at that he's doing it now I
can't even look I'm flushing here is
good yeah yeah yeah do you think people
go into the job their face
suits yeah but i' I in rare occasions I
have seen just like beautiful model
looking girls working at like a gas
station or something I love it and
there's always like what's going on here
or like I want to save you or something
you know like it's there's always
something like that yeah um but I just
feel like yeah like if you look like
that and work like if Jay worked out at
Pet Boys like he wouldn't get be able to
get through the day without somebody
asking him something like you know I
feel like he'd somebody would walk in
there an agent and go hey do you want to
get signed right right right right like
isn't Meg Ryan was like that right
really yeah I think she what I didn't
know that yeah she was discovered like
some people just get Henry Lao was
walking through in high school a mall
with his friends a Korean woman just
pulled him can you sing and dance oh
that's really how it happened yeah and
he goes not really you want to go to
school and he went to Korea and learned
oh wow do people still get discovered at
malls not anymore right I think that if
you're Margo Margo Robbie oh yeah
somebody would go hey you act cuz I feel
like all the castings like on like you
just find someone's Instagram now like
is someone are people still looking
around for talent like in the wild I
could see it happening K-pop still
Scouts like Nationwide every you know
month well you know they were you know
for the movie Rush more yeah they they
were looking forever for that Lee guy
and then I think it was the casor was at
the copas for some sort of party and
they saw um Jason schwarzman there
younger obviously and they go are you an
actor he's like I'm the drummer for the
band Phantom Planet but he went and read
and got it right I mean so people get
discovered you talking about Jason
schwarzman yeah but he's also a Copa you
don't get
this he's at the cop's house
you don't get you don't you're not a
Copa and get discovered that's not how
it works yeah you do he did only the
biggest name in
film like no Bobby well it's not like
he's like francis's son regardless like
he's in the FR sister son he's at the
right place Kia Shire who was in Rocky
and The Godfather right there's
connection there you're right and
Nicholas KES his cousin you're right
you're right so oh you're right but I
promise you he has a relationship with
Francis Ford you know what I mean oh
they hug and kiss on the cheek exactly I
mean Robert um Robert um schwarzman said
that um you know some one time he ran
into his cousin Nicholas C you know it's
like a joyous event you know what I mean
they're they're family if you guys were
born um big time nepo babies if let's
say you were Copa your last name was
Copa or like Scorsese no let's go Asian
okay let's so who am I yo um like yo y
oh or Jackie Michael Yo oh yeah Jackie
Chan okay Michael Yo the comic orich yo